congratulations everybody's winners all
the winners tonight thank you for these
just drop-dead gorgeous beautiful films
so before you leave here tonight I ask
you to think for a moment not just about
what you have received but about what
you still have to give because most of
all tonight we ask you to believe to
believe that together your generation
will share an awesome journey to help
lift up millions through the power of
film so keep writing keep producing art
keep taking us to places we never
imagined and only dream only you could
dream of and keep believing that because
of your creativity and conscience in
your heart someone somewhere when they
least expect it but both but most needed
will recognise their own reflection in
your vision because of your gift someone
somewhere will stand a little taller
think a little differently about their
neighbor walk a difficult road with more
certainty winners all yours is a gift
not a gift to display on your mantle or
rest in your trophy case but a gift to
share with the world so student Academy
Award recipients go light up the world
you guys thank you and good night